نعم عبد السلام هنا اجواء تفاؤل وفرحه
اللي عند فريق البحث والانقاذ التركي
الخاص بهيئه الاغاثه
والمساعدات التركيه اياها حيث استطاعوا
اخراج خمسه اشخاص احياء من عائله واحده
بعد 130 ساعه على وجودهم تحت الانقاض وهي
اشبه بالمعجزه كما يقول فريق الانقاذ
التركي معي الان السيد يوسف وهو رئيس فريق
الانقاذ الخاص بهيئه الاغاثه التركيه
اساله كيف استطاعوا اخراج هؤلاء الخمسه
اشخاص بيشكي
السلام عليكم
الحمد لله والناس
يقول انه في الساعه الثانيه عشره والنصف
بعد
ظهر اليوم بداوا بالعمل في هذا الموقع
تواصلوا مع الاب استطاع الاب ان تحدثه
ويخبرهم عن مكانهم الخمسه الاشخاص الحمد
لله استطاعوا الوصول اليهم وكانوا
بصحه جيده
اللهم
يقول انه الحمد لله هم خرجوا بصحه جيده
ونقلوهم الى المستشفى عبر سيارات الاسعاف
وبقيوا ساعه هنا كانت صحتهم جيده
واخرجوا ونقلوا الى مكان الاسعافات هذا
بالنسبه لهم كان معجزه شيء اشبه بالمعجزه
ان يستطيعوا نحن ربما نعطيكم صوره للمكان
حجم هذا المكان المدمر في نورداغوا اينما
تذهب فيها تشاهد هذا المشهد يعني كل مكان
تذهب له تعتقد انه هو هذا المكان الاكبر
تضررا في مدينه نورداغ الاليات والفرق
الانقاذ من تركيا ومن اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه افاد ومن هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه اياها بالاضافه الى فرق الدعم
التي متواجده من خارج تركيا من قطر ومن
ماليزيا ومن الهند متواجده وتقدم الدعم
والعاليات تعمل على مدار الساعه في محاوله
لانقاذ ناجين ايضا تم اخراج عدد من الجثث
من هذا المكان والعمل متواصل يقولون انهم
يريدون الوصول الى
جثتين الان في مكان قريب
استطاعوا التاكد من وجود جثتين في احد
الابنيه المدمره ويعملون على اخراجهم
العمل متواصل في نورداغ في اينما تذهب
هناك عشرات الاليات تعمل بشكل متواصل فرق
الامداد تصل من
داخل المدينه والى اطراف المدينه وان
اليوم تجولت في مدينه
مدينه نورداغ تجولت
شاهدت الخيم منصوبه في كل مكان هناك ما
يعني انا على الاقل شاهدت ما يقرب من عشره
مخيمات للخيم
نصبت في مختلف مناطق مدينه نورداغ هناك
قطر الخيريه نصبت اكثر من مخيم في اطراف
المدينه وافاد نصبت اكثر من مخيد مخيم في
محيط المدينه وكذلك اياها نصبت مخيمات لها
في مختلف المدينه وكنا نشاهد من بصباح منذ
ان وصلنا الى هذا المكان سيارات المساعدات
للجمعيات الاهليه والجمعيات الدوليه تصل
الى مدينه نورداغ لكن كل الذي يصل هو
لا يكفي حاجه هذه المدينه المنكوبه التي
تضررت بنسبه 80% على الاقل وسكانها صاروا
يعيشون في العراق